either we figure out
creating our own lives together or
separately
scott disick is apparently ready to
settle down with kourtney kardashian
and admits he gets super jealous when
court dates other people
waking up to like looking at pictures of
you
and like with this guy you were dating
and you know it was just like unhealthy
and like
it just made me upset and sad you know
what i mean well that's at least the
case and a sneak peek at keeping up with
the kardashians
i'm just like living life and whatever
happens happens
the reality star says he gets
uncomfortable when his ex is even
talking to another man in my head like
seeing you
around any guy bothers me
around another human that i'm not
flirting with
maybe it's just something i don't know i
feel like you're like a little flirty or
you're like
not i promise then it's my insecurity
then i feel like
that i just don't like
seeing you with another guy or a guy
it hurt me when you're with somebody
else at the time the two films this
scene
court and scott were both single and
scott admits
he has a hard time when she's dating
waking up to like
looking at pictures of you and like with
this guy you were dating
and you know it was just like unhealthy
and like it just made me upset and sad
you know what i mean
and now i wake up like with no real
problems like you know what i mean i'm
like
carefree in the sense like i don't have
that but
the big fear is if you start dating
again
then it goes back to that and i have to
feel like a different way again
yeah and it's just hard it sucks
and scott even proposes that they
rekindled their relationship
now that like you're single and i'm
single and you haven't been with
somebody in a bit
either we figure out
creating our own lives together or
separately
court and scotch are three children
together eleven-year-old mason
eight-year-old penelope and
six-year-old reign and the two have
managed to stay friends and
co-parent together something scott
opened up to et about back in 2019.
i mean i think you just gotta figure out
really what's important to you at the
end of the day
at the end of the day i mean you just
want to be happy you want to be content
you want to be comfortable it's
definitely difficult that courtney and i
basically spend
90 of our lives together travel together
do everything together see each other
every day
and you know the only difference is at
the end of the night we kind of part
ways and go and sleep in separate
houses and this whole limbo state
isn't that cool anymore and i surely
don't want us both to wake up and be 50
years old
and doing the same thing of course scott
is currently dating 19 year old model
amelia hamlin
and the push founder is getting serious
with travis barker
a source recently told et that the blink
182 drummer is quote
so in love and infatuated with the
reality star
adding that they are having the best
time together
quote he's 100 all in and totally sees a
future with her
courtney is living her best life and is
truly so happy
as for scott the source says it's been
an adjustment for him getting used to
court and travis's serious relationship
quote he is still trying to get used to
it scott is still close with courtney
but things between them have
changed a bit i think we've been through
so much in so many things
a source told et earlier this month that
court is the happiest she has been in a
long time
and her family is thrilled for her quote
courtney's been trying to keep their
relationship
as private as she can on social media
but they're both
super into each other and cute together
[Music]